so I want to ask you a few spoiler
questions that are going to run after
the film is out but um you have some
great cameos and I want to ask
specifically about them yeah so anyone
who's listening who has not seen the
film earmuffs
um but let's talk about the Ryan
Reynolds one was that a result of Chris
doing free guy
show answers yes I mean that's what I
understand it so we were always trying
to get Ryan to come in he was going to
play one of the bounty hunters in fact
you know there's that sequence with with
John and Anthony and and Sebastian and
he was going to be one of those guys but
he it turned out he couldn't do he had a
commitment he said but I'm absolutely
committed to coming and doing what so
then we started thinking about it and
the writer said well wouldn't it be
funny if one of these bounty hunters in
the big shootout at the end was an ex of
Sadies which was just a great idea
um so he came on the day that he came
and I went in the trailer and just to
chat about the scene what the idea was
because he essentially kind of came up
with that idea for you know what he says
and I was like so great you're doing it
he was like look when I needed Evans I
picked up the phone I didn't really know
him that well then I was like will you
come and do it he was there the next day
he said so I'm all in for what you you
know what when Chris picks up the phone
I'm there and it's not gonna like the
thing if you owe me something I think
it's just about we're all trying to do
the best we can we want to make good
films we want to make films that people
enjoy and want to see and we'll
hopefully watch again and and I think
the industry is actually quite small and
there's no Givens you know there's no
guarantees you know it's it's hard to
make something good and if everyone can
contribute to that and generally people
are nice and Ryan Reynolds is a nice guy
but he's a good guy so him and Chris are
like yeah now they'll play this tennis
game of well you owe me and I owe you
and you owe me and maybe long might
continue I say yeah and Ryan is also
um very good at coming up with dialogue
and writing in the moment I mean all I
mean the outtakes on that are they
really got I mean it was like I could
have made that scene much much longer I
really had to make a really brutal
decision about
I could have cut some of this down
because there's the action is going on
she's sort of stopped to you know
fortunately she has that bullet wound
and anyway but but yeah he did this
whole thing about driving I'm a really
good listener hour drive a really
sensible mini size a minivan and I'm a
really good listener and he went into
this speech about
anyway you can imagine it was very good
sure I also want to touch on the the
sequence when I saw the film for the
first time I didn't know what was going
to happen obviously uh you hadn't heard
anything and that sequence with Anthony
Sebastian and John yeah I'll get you
know killed and that I think it's a
great sequence but it's also fantastic
because of the actors portraying the
bounty hunters so can you talk about
getting those three guys in the film and
how that all came about well again that
was in the script there was different
names in the script but but recent one
it could written in
it should be this person and the second
Bounty Hunter should be this person and
and it ended up with being a
a huge star at the end you know and so
that was in there that was always the
idea but I
approached it was like how important is
this to the story how important is and
really what it's about for me as the
Storyteller is about oh the world
they're in is dangerous there's very
real threat and they are now hunted
that's what's really important so that
as as moving forward is that how I
directed the sequence I just happen to
have these incredible actors who were
willing you know when Chris picks up the
phone for Mackie and goes get yourself
down here and Mackie turns up and says
oh man if I don't it was at night time I
would have said no you know which is
it's cool because he turns out for a
night you know to Atlanta and and does
the scene is brilliant
um but I just think it speaks to their
friendship you know and John was someone
I just always admired and wanted to work
with and and I it was a name that I just
threw out there as someone I thought
would be really great and they came back
when he's agreed so I was like and
Sebastian I know a bit as well and
um of course Chris does but he he he was
just there instantly I mean it was it
was quite unbelievable really
um but knowing them it's not really
unbelievable I think they're all
they're all very excited and I think
they've got the gag they like the gag I
think they like the sequence they knew
that they were yeah how long did it
actually take to film that specific
sequence with those actors one night for
each of them
one night oh wow so yeah you know and it
was a little bit of crossover with John
and oh no no Mackie yeah it was a
different night from John and Sebastian
got covered the first time he wanted to
shoot him and that's come back a later
date
so that was that was really tricky
because that so that made things really
but but but but one we had each for a
day or a night and they came in did it
and went hey we love you guys good luck
looks great bye we still up they went
you know
um
so that was just and I I think what's
lovely it just
you know it's a lovely scene anyway the
scene prior to that with with Sadie's
ex-boyfriend
um which I think is very funny and is
very good and he's a fantastic actor
Marlon canzari and um it just sort of
added to the whole the whole midsection
of the film really